it's been a pretty good news weekend for
fans of rare the studio behind n64
classics like Goldeneye and stinky Kong
Country given that the company are now
hyping up their new project and former
depths have had their spiritual
successor to banjo kazooie kick-started
platonic as AB studio formed by former
rare veterans including the lead
programmers character and world
designers behind banjo kazooie and dog
song country launched a kickstarter
campaign for their 3d platformer ukulele
and had it successfully funded within 24
hours the project has quickly gone on to
raise over 1.2 million pounds at the
time of recording that converts to a lot
of dollars the project has busted all
that stretch goals leaving platonic to
create a few new one including an
optical n54 shader mode and a DK wrap in
the spirit of the infamous DK wrap in
Donkey Kong Country ukulele will be
released on pc ps4 xbox one and we used
the kickstarter campaign still has 44
days to go meanwhile the people still a
prayer tease their upcoming project in
response to ukuleles success while they
wouldn't say whether it would be a 3d
platformer creative director Simon
Woodruff said it wouldn't be next game
and it would be more fun than anything
they'd ever done let me know what you
think of ukulele and what you reckon
rare is going to come out with to their
upcoming project as always for the
latest on both of these stay tuned to
gamespot
you